we must continue to focus to stick to
the plan for 2016
marijuana enforcement has been
fundamental to the erosion of our
constitutional rights replacing that
with a legal system opens different
questions the pitch is at prohibition
has only created you know crime violence
and the separation and destruction of
families it's time to end prohibition
California set the stage for marijuana
legalization in America as the first
state to legalize the drug for medical
use with the passage of prop 215 in 1996
but after the Golden State failed to
legalize commercial marijuana sales in
2010 several states and the District of
Columbia beat Prague to California and
showed the nation what a recreational
pot market would look like but now
California is back in the game reason TV
traveled to Oaksterdam University the
nation's premier cannabis cultivation
school where many of the political
activists pushing an upcoming ballot
initiative held a meeting to finalize
language and debate some of the finer
points of legalization the group calls
itself reform CA and is chaired by
Oaksterdam president Dale Skye Jones
we spoke to Sky Jones in several other
activists about lessons learned from
prop 19 what other states can teach
California and what legalization in the
largest state in the Union would mean
for the rest of the country coming off
of the loss of prop 19 in 2010 we
realized that we had an awful lot of
work to do to get it right for
California in the coming years back in
2010 it was the first introduction of
the idea of adult use of cannabis so it
was a you know testing the market so to
speak I would never in favor of a 2010
effort because uh polls were too close
and it was an off year election I
campaigned against prop 19 I thought
prop 19 was bad policy I thought it was
poorly thought-out and I thought it was
too soon even though I'm a political
consultant I understand
that some issues need to fail before
they win and I think to everyone's
surprise with proposition 19 is they
expected it to come not even close
and instead you know it came in at forty
eight percent it missed by you know
three points and if it wasn't for
proposition 19 there wouldn't have been
the propositions that we saw in Colorado
Washington State Washington DC Alaska so
it was a precursor prop 19 may have
paved the way for legalization in other
states but now legalization advocates
believe California needs to learn some
important lessons from Colorado
Washington Oregon Alaska and Washington
DC I think the most important thing that
these states that have already chosen to
regulate for adult consumption of
cannabis offers is that there's proof
the sky has not fallen all of the scare
tactics the marijuana madness that has
been put forth by those that would
prefer to keep the failed status quo
have been proven wrong and at a certain
point we can hold people accountable to
the lies that they've told Washington
state Colorado they were very much
interested in the tax revenues message
is that it is going to be well regulated
well controlled like alcohol it's only
goes to adults a few of the what not to
do is that we've learned have
specifically come from Washington State
not to beat up on one of the first
because they did get it over the line
and that's important to note the taxes
that they initially envisioned were way
too high
Colorado probably did it best overall in
the way that they brought folks into a
regulated system a taxation system and
manage to keep intervention from the
federal government away in the process
Colorado is also very burdensome
cumbersome and expensive and in fact
many of the things that folks tout as
Colorado law with that seed to sale
tracking and how stringent it is isn't
actually that stringent anymore because
they realized it was ridiculously
expensive there is not a cop watching
every plant out there the day before
this meeting took place the state
legislature for the first time passed
uniform regulations that treat medical
marijuana the same across the state I
wish that the ledge had passed this last
year I'm having flashbacks of 2010 the
October surprise when Schwarzenegger
signed in a decriminalization measure
saying why legalized we decriminalized
and I'm worried that we're going to hear
why legalized we finally just regulated
medical let's wait till 2020 the Blue
Ribbon Commission was first formed with
lieutenant governor Gavin Newsom at the
halma Stearman I'd say the Lieutenant
Governor himself is an excellent
qualifier for how far we've come he was
against brought my team at the time and
he is now heading up this commission the
commission generated a giant report full
of recommendations I would say the
single most important issue that I would
recommend is that there be rigorous
collection of data with legalization we
have to have information about the
consumption of marijuana public health
issues public safety issues taxation
regulatory data all of that information
can help us make reasoned judgments on
public policy that are based on fact
reform see a published its initiative in
early October a lot can happen over the
next year including the possibility of
competing initiatives but these
activists remain optimistic and believe
that legalization in California could be
a tipping point in the war on marijuana
some people say there are six
California's it was a there ten
California's as we proceed we're going
to have to basically address the
concerns of each of these California's
and show that it overall it's good to
have a statewide system California has
more producers than the rest of the
country combined we produce more
cannabis and you know a little bit of a
pride here we produce the best cannabis
there's been a groundswell statewide of
growers and small businesses waking up
to the fact that we can't hide from
regulation forever the best possible
outcomes will come by embracing it and
helping to shape it and guide it I
thought that when California legalized
medical marijuana the federal government
would
scheduling or something like that and lo
and behold I was mistaken in that
federal government really has not
changed federal laws an iota in these 20
years nonetheless I do think that the
handwriting is on the wall now and we
have majority votes even in Congress to
let the states follow their own laws in
this regard California represents
one-sixth of the u.s. economy so goes
California so goes the rest of the
nation and likely the rest of the world
everyone is watching and if we don't get
this right we become the redheaded
stepchildren poster child of what not to
do and we're done being that for the
last few years